[Music]
kayla is with us in indianapolis hi
kayla how are you
hi david christie how are you guys great
what's going on
um so i'm currently pregnant i'm due
november 10th with my second son
and this part around i'm doing things a
little differently i'm doing things the
dave way so we're about ready to start
um baby step one and it really makes me
nervous to only have
a thousand dollars one piece here so i
was wondering if we could stay in
historic mode for say six months
um just to get enough for once he's here
and make sure everything's okay and then
we jump into baby step two i know that
the thousand dollars is supposed to push
you and give you that momentum but it
just really makes me nervous only having
a thousand dollars with a newborn
well to start out with um
the uh
we tell you not to do
a and not to do pay money on debt while
you're pregnant so just pile up right
now yeah as big as you can pile until
november 10th but now you've had a baby
this is your second one this is not a
mystery
which is exactly why i'm asking this
question i mean i mean what did you have
how did your life financially turn
upside down in the first six months
they just eat formula and diapers
true but i didn't have a very supportive
partner we're no longer together and he
actually doesn't even help with with my
son so that's not the case with my
husband but i'm saying i know what can
happen and like if something happened
with michael what could happen
if something happened with my car your
car babies break cars
no they don't but if i needed that money
for him i'm just i'm just not sure if a
thousand dollars is sitting on a
thousand dollars you don't need that
money for him you needed it for the car
a minute ago
kayla
let me jump in here let me jump in here
okay
so the the the mindset typically when we
talk about saving up while you're
pregnant is the idea is to get the baby
safely here when your baby is safely
here which is what we would pray for and
hope for for you you've done this before
that's the idea then once the baby's
here and you've adjusted and you give
yourself a minute then yes you can go
back to paying off debt because
things are different now what i hear in
your question and maybe i'm reading into
it but what i hear in your question is
kayla you've got some wounds from how
this went last time you didn't have a
supportive partner last time you had to
do things on your own that was scary and
that that fear is still with you and i
hear you but what we encourage people to
do is we want you to make decisions
based on facts not on fear right now
sounds like you're in a great situation
you've got some money saved up you're
going to keep saving up when the baby is
here safely you can begin to pay on that
debt again and you will be bringing this
baby home with the supportive spouse in
a different situation so i just want to
encourage you yes that fear taught you
something but we don't have to live in
that fear and worry because there's no
amount of money that's going to relieve
that fear that that seems like that's
that past wound talking to me and the
idea is we want to get that baby here
when you get the baby here safely you
can start to pay on that debt again once
baby's here and safe in your situation
hon
the reason i'm poking at you is 99 of
your world is predictable
it is it is formula diapers and
pediatrician bills and they become part
of the budget
and you don't need an emergency fund for
those things and there's not there's no
boogie monster in the closet there's
just not um does maternity leave factor
into that at all unpaid maternity leave
that's another reason i guess you're
gonna have to put that in your budget
right
okay i mean if you guys can you live on
his income
um yeah i believe so it would be very
tight right now we make around 90 000
both of us what does he make
he makes
that take home for both of us he makes
85. okay
on his own and that's not and you make
five
he comes about 5 000 a month for him for
me it's almost four thousand a month i'm
sorry i'm uh oh i thought you said he
made eighty five thousand a year
he does that's that's not take-home
though his take-home is is about five so
it makes forty-three you can live on
eighty five thousand dollars a year
with two babies
you can do it why do you feel like you
can't kayla do you have too much house
or she doesn't have a budget that's why
she doesn't so you're you're dealing
with all these emotional stuff and
you're dealing with no facts at all
and you're dealing with the past wounds
that christie's talking about and you've
got this vague thing in your head you
just told me your husband makes 85 000 a
year and you have two kids if you miss
out a little bit of income while you
have oh you're out on maternity leave
zippy
tighten up the old belt and stay out of
the restaurants
you can do this that's very very very
doable okay um
so yeah
don't add pregnancy drama to this
discussion it's just all you got to do
is lay out these numbers and and walk it
straight through this is very doable
christy's done it rachel's done it
you've done it you can do it
and the one thousand dollars is not a
problem not a problem at all